hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the chancre chess tournament
which is the Kashima Memorial we have we
have a game between Magnus Carlsen and
the Dingley Wren and before we start the
game there's there is efore for some
reason on the board already before we
start the game I have a question for you
and don't search the comments or don't
don't try to browse the Internet just
try and see if you can actually remember
can you remember when was the last time
Dingley Rijn lost a game in classical
time format so not blitz non-rapid but
when was the last time ding Liron lost a
game in classical time format but we'll
get back to this after the game so this
is the last round caution is leading the
tournament by half a point and ding
women basically needs a win against
Carlsen to win gushy move memorial 2018
and he has the black pieces against the
world champion
so Carson opens with E for we have E 5
Knight to f3 knight c6 Knight to c3 and
Knight to f6 the four Knights opening or
the four Knights game Bishop to b5 at
the Spanish variation of the four
Knights and now the England goes four
Knights to d4 this is somewhat of a well
you're not gonna see this variation
played too much on a high level or
although I've seen some games it's a
very old variation it's a called
Rubinstein variation I think the first
instance this opening was used was in a
game Rubinstein Akiba Rubinstein himself
used it against Bogoliubov in 1920
although Rubinstein lost that game but
nevertheless so nice the d4 Knight
captures pawn captures and now II five
it's interesting if I've could be the
strongest idea now I have no idea how
the theory goes about this variation but
there are a couple of options you could
go Knight d5 but after Knight captures
pawn captures then white also has
doubled pawns
so not really something white wants to
do i other thing after he captures none
before you could go for a nice key to
and who knows maybe this is what the
England was hoping for to maybe get
maybe get an interesting
and perhaps some winning chances so
after for example Knight captures Knight
captures and Bishop to c5 are you you
could go into a very sharp variation
with Knight to f5 where white would
actually allow a capture and f2 but
capturing an f2 doesn't really give
black anything if you get captured with
the bishop simply King to f1 and
capturing with the knight loses the
Queen e2 and I have to remove the King
rook F 1 I will trap this night so a lot
of ideas here but cousin didn't want to
have any of this after he captures and
before he went for a 5 he wants to
exchange pieces as cousin only needs a
draw to win this tournament so D
captures on c3 we have ich afters on f6
and Queen captures on f6
and cousin immediately goes for a queen
to e2 this comes with check and ding
blocks at Queen to e7 offers a trade of
Queens not afraid of going into into an
equal and game against Carlsen D
captures on c3 Queen Queen captures King
captures and Bishop to c5 so basically
the position is pretty much the same
both players have a bishop pair both
players have 7 points two rooks only
cousins pawn structure is somewhat worse
than the endings as he does have a CC
pawn but it's nothing nothing nothing
black can really take advantage of a
bunch of to e3 but rip capture screen
captures there's no point in keeping the
King anywhere safe it's the endgame the
King has to has to play an active role
c6 Bishop to d3 we have d5 and now rook
a to e1 King to e7 and now we have c4 so
underling the pawns pawn captures Bishop
captures and now rook to d8 we have
looked to d1 cousin wants to simplify
the position even further
bunch of to e6 Bishop capture screen
captures and now rook to e1
now it's a completely equal position
rock captors were captures rook to e8
now we have F 4 F 5 into 3 root 3 7 and
now rook to e1 check came to f6 rook to
d1 King back to e6
Giri basically offers a threefold
repetition as he really can't hope for
for anything more here so Rocky one king
of six rugby one King e6 and after
rookie one
it's a three-fold repetition the players
agreed to a draw so that's the game and
it's a it's an interesting idea going
for this Rubinstein variation but car
cost and immediately 1:45 exchanged to a
pair of nights and then exchanged Queens
and then it's he really will not lose
this game but yeah the game was drawn
here and how many of you could remember
the last time
ding livin lost the game with the in in
classical time for me I tried to
remember and then I thought ok he played
that no he didn't lose the game there
and when I finally checked ok let me
just I do have it prepared
I just haven't loaded it in my interface
okay so let's just load it ok so here
are the England's games in classical
time format from 2018 so there we have
games from the world chess championship
candidates and you have games from the
old games from the Kashima Memorial so
if you look at this there is not a
single loss for Dingley reign he has a
win against Muhammad er off in the world
championship candidates and he has a win
against navara Hiroshima memorial and
also I went against Ralph Mamedov also
from Greenville Memorial and there you
can see the last game custom versus ding
leerin this is this was a draw so so far
in 2018 not a single loss Ford England
so I had to D even further to find when
was the last time ding leavin actually
lost the game in classical time format
and I was able to find it it was a game
against eleven Iranian played in the
World Cup and released the Georgia last
year in September so that's like a long
long time ago over half a year passed
since the England lost his last
classical game so quite an achievement
and you know I think he just needs like
a little little more to start really
winning games ok he did have that match
against
Carson if you all remember the champions
showdown where he had a lot of rapid
games and a lot of blitz games against
Carson there
Carson really annihilated him but those
weren't classical games those were
Blitzen rapid and here okay I did
prepare the the standings for you let me
just loaded those here are the standings
ledges let's just see that okay
Hashim of Memorial Tournament final
standings there we have it magnus
carlsen first with six ro9 three wins 0
losses six draws and then follows
Dingley run would five and a half also
without a single loss
Mahmoud yar of with four and a half out
of nine one win one loss and seven rows
then way taschek radoslav also
four-and-a-half onigiri four and a half
and tomorrow job also four and a half
the motor job of only player with know
he's not the only player oh wait what's
this ah sorry I these are the final
standings before one game one game is
still going on so the this doesn't
really the final standings but okay
cousin will always be first you can see
that the polo is for our out of eight
and kurakin is four out of eight but
even if even if okay if some of if any
any of them win then we can have either
to Paulo or Kirk in third place instead
of mummy the earth so that's one thing
that can happen I will inform you about
this in my in my next video or I will
add it in the comment yeah I didn't take
that into account that one game was
still being played but yeah that's
basically it I do hope you enjoyed it
and I do hope you enjoyed this
tournament so a very nice one by Carlson
and he shows that he's still you know in
in top form even though he describes his
game as the mediocre but he is still
able to win such such an elite
tournaments such as the Kashima memorial
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank Nancy Aubry
glia Gabriel Jackson Mathias vinnitsky
and border patrol in for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
I think all for watching and I will see
you soon and of course as usual you can
check to my previous videos here
thank you